penati non era così però va bene i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo lo video
sono valigie e oggi siamo su socket
league con lo stesso né nazionale e
buona visione a tutti quanti papà papà
perché sono tutti i francesi che giocano
rocket league
me l'hanno programma abbiamo la
giochiamo all'italiana un bar del paese
vuoi fare il francese fallo pure di dal
formez
però io non li ascolterò mezzo fra le
fan 6 eccolo tra los aperti in mezzo per
l'italia anche il suo muro si è scattato
e travers a zidane di zidane dove è
carico lo sa bene come ha fatto a
segnare la divisione ambato là dietro
io ricordo che era dato al contrario tra
italia francia no a liceo assegnato loro
bebè la meta facile baguette o anche se
la prende e chi è bellissimo è accaduto
neanche noi già creduto nodo bampo la
vampa tu non ci sei a pensare adesso che
avete tolto la vita c'è comunque bisogno
io ok allora più capito è il gol più
brutto che puoi fare solo che per lippi
guarda guarda bello st guerra danni e
non basta ancora devo spingere pure lui
è diventata numerica d'ufficio spiller
si stava staccando dal muro al punto
giusto è la preda all'ultimo momento
cosa mamma mia nonna banche ok il
successo tutto a posto
è stato bravo perché l'avevo messa
ma è presa dollari e proprio gol ma non
si va ad altro e buono io ci credo e lo
faccio peschici che non lo stesso mamma
mia cosa vi devo dire signori bella va
bene sai che gruppo vi riguarda quindi
secondo me lui l'avrebbe parata perché
l'ho anticipato
secondo seguito guarda quanto per me
l'aveva parata si separava la parola
certo la parola no ma questa cosa perché
non sono capace l'avevo visto partire
occhio ma cosa ma cos'è ma cos'è ma
cos'è di voi
ok proprio che la destra signori
niente con i banchi è bella poi grazie a
dio ho il video tutto quello che voleva
fare leva di mega anticipo se riesce ad
essere se non esce paziente e anche oggi
la francia può andare a casa
anche oggi la francia anni tra fare le
forse non è come non si avrebbero però
loro ci credono funzione che non è
finita ma se c'erano ancora un tiro
bonus ai cortei collega ok pdf a
controllo ciao amici grazie a prossima
ma che avatar anno ma anche mela
racconteranno la loro cg di no ma che
cosa ha fatto quel mercato di come si
gioca sentito anche io
bella ok prova un cross ma solo perché
l'hai chiamata se non sarei mai andato
il motivo
niente né turbo sono le speranza vero e
ha funzionato
va bene nyman agli prossima avuto paura
no questo sarei stoccata benissimo ma
non è per ora voleva fare questo però
quando sarà carico vabbè dai s'installa
dove morì andare in attacco ma allora ci
bloccano ce l'ho mai passato tensione
potrebbe essere voi noi razelli dava già
volando per lo consiglio la palla tutto
qua ok aspetto che scenda per ripartire
con calma
bellissima che peccato cacchio allora
dovrei tornare in tempo si no ma perché
si era allentata l'auto lì non ho capito
ma deve avermi spiegato qualcosa magari
con fregato come lo frega altro come lo
fregato avevo intuito tutto tutto a 20
del pressing e cattiva al punto giusto
ml è tranquillo
a fare questa cosa che vedi finché non
la prenderà una palla più forte di me
mamma mia sono chiamati bling che parla
siamo andati in autostrada giocare
abbiamo fatto nella vita
forse gli umiliati ha detto proprio ciao
ci vorrebbe bellizzi di attenzione
categoria bella si è sempre lì pro bella
all'asti girato e l'ha presa malissimo
la propria valuta talento che si
annuncia di non ci credevo ok rimane la
notevoli i dribbling e ovviamente centro
ma mai mai mai
ma questo non rende no no no da sé che
stavo giocando senza guardare il
punteggio ma perché abbastanza a
saltarti vedi che serve guardare il
punteggio
scusami amico mio se la mia squadra me
lo devo ricordare toccarla e che la
guerra dello stretto dal dischetto
santissima dentro unica del 20 per tutta
la pall
beh allora non allora non hanno il tasto
del suo rende capito le hanno tolto e
quindi niente parte del 40 tecnologica
anticipo quale ha ripercorso lo guarda
da che dai temi etici fatto niente è
rovinato il momento arc
niente non riuscite una volta andava
bene agli a natale con loro tensione non
è vero perché era contrario ci ha
provato per te ci provano ero andato a
coprirlo fermare gli darei un consiglio
allora secondo me dovrebbero andare a
riposarsi non andare più per riposarsi
non devono non devono giocare la
prossima partita secondo me per esempio
per richiedere contro mette hanno
bisogno di ricompense che stanno
giocando da stamattina e quindi sono un
po scarichi lo spero per la fiore
attenzione neanche nella barriera 6 a 0
così va bene i ragazzi vivono oggi è
finito ringrazio su stefan e per avermi
cariati io ho cambiato lui facciamo un
po di caring a vicenda e quindi spero
che vi scriviate a canale e lasciate un
commento mi piace a noi come sempre ci
diamo hanno così bella ragazzi
[Musica]